ich habe schon Ämter als gebrochener
Mensch verlassen also er war sehr nette
Leute in Verwaltung erlebt aber auch
extrem unfreundliche so sind Menschen
halt könnte man sagen ja absolut aber
als Bürger soll es ja nicht vom Glück
abhängen ob mir jemand das Formular
erklärt es ist Teil ihres Jobs folglich
zu sein ich erwarte ja nicht dass
Annemarie danach zu mir sagt du ich habe
heute Rouladen gemacht magst Du
vielleicht mit Essen ich erwarte nur
nicht mega unfreundliche Menschen auf
dem Abend weil sie verrückte Idee einen
serviceberuf haben die Flugbegleiterin
im Flugzeug kriegen auch nicht Geld weil
sie so toll Notausgänge zeigen können
sondern weil sie das Flugzeug nicht
anzünden wenn der Junggesellenabschied
zum 14 Mal Leila sin